what i'm optimistic about
is this idea
that we can redesign the road in the
future
that we don't have to have a road or a
society or a country structured for
inequitable and equal outcomes that
there's literally things we can do
not with a magic wand
but with hard work and with truth to
create a future again that we all
deserve to live in and before going to
the policy prescriptions let's talk
about the truth
because we also know that in our society
a big part of the way this road is
maintained and graveled and made sure it
stays the way it is are the lies or the
narratives we tell about how we came to
be
we know it's hard to solve the issue of
poverty
if the ubiquitous thought is that people
are poor because they want to be poor
we know it's impossible to create a
future free of poverty
when we believe that people are poor
because they're dumber than people with
money
we we know it's difficult to imagine or
create a world or a future free of
avoidable impairment of basic human
needs
when we believe that somehow that
there's a natural order to things that
somehow this hierarchy of human value we
tolerate our society is okay so the
first thing we have to do when thinking
about the future is tell the truth and
the truth is this
talent and intellect are truly
evenly distributed but resources
opportunities are not
the folks i went to school with at
stanford weren't necessarily smarter
naturally biologically genetically than
the folks i grew up with in stockton but
they had the best schools the best
teachers the best summer enrichment
programs the the best tutors for 20
years
after already being born with an
insurmountable head start we know that
the truth is that we list miss out on so
much
just recently in the new york times
there's an article about the einstein
called the einstein effect and it talks
about how high-performing and math
low-income children
were less likely to get inventions and
patents than the worst performing rich
children
and that's not a question of merit
that's not a question of ability that's
a question of inputs resources and in
structure but that is something that
that we're able to change and we know on
the policy front what works particularly
for the issue of not having money
and it's not
teaching people how to manage money they
don't have
it's not mentorship
it it's not um unpaid labor
it it's not a minimum wage that is lower
than the cost of living in every city in
this country
but it is cash
and one of the things i did in the in
the old days when i was still an elected
official was we gave people money
and this was in 2017
before the pandemic
before my good friend andrew yang before
we had 80 mayors as a part of marriage
for guaranteed income before we had 100
guaranteed compilots going on in this
country before san francisco had 12
pilots happening here in the city
and it came from this realization number
one it came from the imagination
of someone who grew up in poverty
it took someone who grew up in poverty
to start the first basic income program
in the country and i just want to pause
there for a second because i think it's
again it's incredibly important in this
conversation about the future to
understand that those
most impacted by the problem
have solutions
they have answers they have the radical
imagination needed to liberate us from
from from some of the nightmarish lies
we've all in internalized it was really
that lived experience that gave birth to
this idea that let's try giving people
money and what we saw is is no surprise
because people are people
we saw that people spent money the way
you and i spend money because people are
people they spent the money on their
kids they spent their money on utilities
they spent their money on food and they
spent their money on getting their
uniforms clean and we also saw that the
money
did not make people stop working
wow
the 500
was not enough for people to stop
working
instead what we saw
is that people were able to work more
because we saw that for folks living on
the margins for folks living in poverty
that 500 was a difference between
affording child care or not
that five hundred dollars was a
difference between be able to get your
car fixed or not that thousand dollars
was a difference from being able to take
time off your job
where you don't have paid time off so
you can't go interview for a better job
without the risk of losing money and say
you know how much bet on myself
and go ahead and do
an interview and get a full-time job
that pays more and allows you to work
less as we saw
time and time again and five years later
now we have again 80 mayors who are
saying yes let's figure out what
guaranteed income looks like we had a
child tax credit
which cut child poverty in half and
somehow folks in dc thought that was a
bad idea so let's
with inflation coming let's cut this in
the child tax credits to make all the
kids poor again we have momentum around
this idea and i think the future has to
be one where we all agree that no one
should be poor that
no one
should live in poverty that no one
should be homeless and if those sounds
like radical notions
they're not because you don't live in
poverty
you don't live in scarcity
you don't live unhoused and unsheltered
so if it's good enough for you
it should be good enough for everyone
that's not saying everyone needs the
same but it is to say like what type of
future would we have
if not one that understands that
everyone has the same basic human value
and everyone needs at least a baseline
level of security to be human that
everyone needs at least the basics
shelter
food
water the ability to pay bills and again
we have policy tools that work and the
question is how building the political
will to get there and again i think that
goes back to the narratives around how
do we talk about the present and how do
we talk about the future and who do we
allow to participate
in the conversation around planning for
the future
another policy solution we can do that
will literally end the wealth gap in
this country
would be baby bonds it's been researched
it's been
um theorized there's literally bills and
state legislature just literally bills
in the u.s senate now that says if you
put just a little bit of money a little
bit of seed money in a child's account
when they're born
you let it grow children have assets so
that the mistakes of the past don't have
to dictate or or or narrow their future
and and again we know what it can do
there's been models there's really bills
in congress now there's a bill in the
state legislature that just passed at
least for kids with covert but this is
something we can do today to prepare for
a future where if there's gaps in wealth
they're truly gaps based off ability if
there's gaps in wealth they're truly
based on gaps in effort
not based off gaps in government
intervention not basing gaps of
marginalization but but that's really
based off merit and i think
i'm having this argument with one of my
friends who thinks about the future
differently than i do
is that what i'm
saying we should want for the future
isn't equal outcomes
but just ones i'll say it again it's not
about
equal outcomes it's about just outcomes
it's about outcomes that are
predicted by the just inputs we put in
and not these wild outcomes we pretend
are based off merit that we pretend are
based off ability that we pretend are
based off how everyone's working because
that creates the dysfunction
all the isms the anxiety the the stress
um that that plagues our society are far
too often today
[Music]
you